[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
so
welcome i'm angela gallan and we are so
glad you are with us today
tonight i would like to highlight two
meetups that are starting this fall
for those that don't know meetups are
small groups here at the table
and they are great ways to get connected
with our community
aside from the sunday evening services
the first is the be the bridge meetup
this group will be meeting for a 15-week
discussion
on christian racial reconciliation
the facilitators will be milagros
martinez and nancy purdy
the meetings will be held on tuesday
evenings from 7 to 9 p.m
on zoom starting on september 22nd
there will be a link in the comments for
the google sign-up form so please fill
that out
space is limited the second
is the enneagram meetup this brand new
group
will be led by joe brock and josh
reynolds
they will be facilitating a six-week
session
on wednesday evening starting on
september 23rd
and runs up until october 28th
space is limited so if you are
interested please email joe
at brock joe josh yahoo.com
there will be a link in the comments for
a meet up interest form
so that you can get information on the
groups that are currently offered
and request information as we transition
into worship
i would love to share a prayer with you
dear lord teach me to trust in you so
that when the unexpected storms of life
come
i will expect peace in the midst of
those storms
knowing that you are near you hear my
cries
and you are with me and for me
amen
hey guys thank you angela
it's good to be with you all i hope that
our time together night is a blessing
and that um that you can find some peace
just like she was saying in the midst of
any storm
um that you would feel the presence of
goodness and life and light that jesus
brings into our life
and that this would be a moment for all
of us to remember that and to encounter
that together
and to make space for it in our lives
[Music]
the storm surrounding me let it break
jesus jesus
you make the darkness triple
your silence fear
jesus jesus
you make the darkness tremble
jesus jesus breathe
call these
[Music]
jesus
you make the darkness
jesus jesus
your silence fear
you make the darkness triple
jesus jesus
you make the darkness
[Music]
jesus jesus
you make the darkness
[Music]
your name is
is
your name is a light
that the shadows can't deny
your name
[Music]
[Applause]
is
you make the darkness tremble jesus
jesus your silence fear
jesus jesus
you make the darkness triple jesus
jesus
[Music]
jesus jesus
preaches jesus
how do i trust
[Music]
jesus jesus
psalm 91 says he who dwells in the
shelter of the most high will rest
in the shadow of the almighty
i will say of god he is my refuge
and my fortress my god in
whom i trust surely he will save me from
the fowler snare
and from the deadly pestilence he will
cover
you with his feathers and under his
wings
you will find refuge his faithfulness
will be
your shield and your rampart you will
not fear the terror of night
nor the arrow that flies by day nor the
pestilence that stalks
in the darkness nor the plague that
destroys
at midday a thousand may fall
at your side ten thousand at your right
hand
but it will not come near you
worthy we could
[Music]
worthy of every we could ever
breathe
[Music]
jesus
of every breath we could ever
[Music]
show me who you are
worthy of every song we could ever
see
[Music]
worthy of all the
every praise we could ever breathe
[Music]
worthy of every breath we
there is
[Music]
show me who you are me
i will build my life
upon your love
it is firm
foundation i
will put my trust
in you
and i will not
[Music]
it is
shaken
[Music]
and i
show me who you are
[Music]
hit and when chaos comes
god that um there's still more
to the story
that we know that this isn't the end
of your work in our lives
[Music]
and who you've called us to be in
accepting your love
and your redemption and your grace in
our lives
[Music]
i'm so grateful that you are
a god that i can trust
[Music]
i believe that at the end of the story
that we
know that good is going to triumph that
your light
is stronger than darkness god that your
peace
overcomes chaos that your truth
outweighs lies
thank you for being bigger and more and
beyond
what we could ask or imagine
love wins and we want to believe that
god for our lives
thank you for who you are and what
you're doing in us and in this community
help us to embrace it it's in jesus name
i pray
amen
amen thank you maggie and mindy and um
before them angela it's wonderful to be
with
all of you so welcome welcome to the
table
grace and peace um so before we
go ahead and jump in tonight i did want
to just encourage you
if you're kind of on the fence maybe
about like joining a meet up
i wanted to encourage you kind of kind
of nudge you towards that be the bridge
group
um it's just it's a really important
class
especially if you find yourself kind of
struggling to make sense of our cultural
moment on the topic of
of race um and really the classes
purpose is just to educate
you know to teach us history history
that we may not have really engaged in
school
and to kind of give us a framework um to
to kind of understand the the tension
that we're we're
living in uh so it's it's basically it's
just the best kind of curriculum we've
come across that can
can do that in kind of the context of
christian um
you know theology and thoughts so um
anyway i just encourage you
to go ahead and sign up at that link and
it is you know it's kind of a time
limited class
so you don't have to like worry about it
being you know a forever commitment i
think it's six weeks
um so at any rate i uh yeah i encourage
you to do that
so uh the title of my message
this evening is every bush of fire
and our primary text is going to be from
exodus chapter
three this is a very uh famous story
from the old testament
and uh be familiar to to
probably many of you but not necessarily
everyone um
so we'll go ahead and start reading here
um starting in verse 1 it says now moses
was tending the flock of jethro his
father-in-law the priest of midian
and he led the flock to the far side of
the wilderness and came to horeb the
mountain of god
there the angel of the lord appeared to
him in flames of fire
from within a bush moses saw
that though the bush was on fire it did
not burn
up so moses thought i will go over
and see this strange sight why the bush
does not burn up when the lord saw
that he had gone over to look god called
to him
from within the bush moses
moses and moses said
here i am do not come any closer
god said take off your sandals for the
place where you are standing
is holy ground then he said
i am the god of your father the god of
abraham the god of isaac and the god
of jacob at this moses hid his face
because he was afraid to look at god
so there's moses tending sheep out in
the middle of nowhere
when suddenly um well i'm tempted to say
that god shows up
but it's not so much that god
wasn't there and then suddenly decided
to drop in for a visit
at least that's not how it's been really
interpreted by the
the greatest minds in church tradition
down to the centuries and said they
would say
that every tree rock person shrub is
sustained by the presence and reality
of god so it's not that god
shows up where he was not before because
every bush is charged with god's radiant
glory but what occurs with moses
is it's a moment of revelation
and unveiling sort of like um when you
go to
say like a live show and they have uh
the curtain
covering the stage and then suddenly the
show begins and
whoosh right the stage is is revealed
so moses is permitted to see
god's uh uncreated eternal glory to kind
of give
get a glimpse of this uh and and here
god's glory manifests
as this beautiful fire that never goes
out uh here's how the english poet
elizabeth barrett browning
put it she would put it quite
beautifully this is she's writing in
like the 1800s
and she said this earth's crammed with
heaven
in every common bush a fire with god
but only he who sees takes off his shoes
the rest sit round it and pluck
blackberries i think um
i think if i had one prayer for us at
the table uh this is kind of a recurring
theme in my messages
it would be the capacity to see to see
that every bush every flower every
creature every person
all creation is as browning says a fire
with a god but truth be told
most of the time we just flat out don't
live like that i don't live like that
uh i mean most of the time now sometimes
sometimes we do sometimes
like we have these moments where we see
as the mystics see
and the world shines in a way that god
suddenly
just seems like the most obvious thing
in the world and while it's true
that very few of us walk around you know
all day every day with this sense of
god's palpable presence i do think
we have moments don't we like these
moments
where the burning bush is unveiled for
us
so to speak at the last church i worked
at
i used to live just about a 10-minute
walk from the the building
and so because of this i either walked
or biked
to to work nearly every day which meant
you know over a period of years i must
have taken this path
kind of through these neighborhoods it
was uh there
in wiley texas across from birmingham
elementary i took that path
who knows five days a week
years you know a lot of times like
hundreds of times
um but one day in particular
i recall i don't remember a lot of
details i just remember i was stressed
and angry i was on my way home it'd been
a hard day
just stressed out i was angry and i
can't remember about what
you know isn't it weird how like stress
and anger just swallow us in the moment
but then a day a week a month
you know later it's like it's like it
never happened um
so i can't remember what but i i was
just freaking out
and i was doing that weird thing where
you argue with someone in your head
you know like the conversation's long
over but you're thinking of like oh
and i should have said oh that that
would have been great but no but then
then he would have said this but then i
could follow up and so
i mean i'm just engaged in this you know
foolish ego driven stupidity
on my walk home so there i am just
arguing away in my brain
not outwardly thankfully i don't know
what the neighbors would think
keep it all inside then it's okay then
it's normal you know as long as it's all
in your head
so there i am and as i recall this whole
time like i'm walking home you know when
you get lost in
in your mind like you're just kind of
looking down you know you're not tuned
into the world
you're not like oh what beautiful birds
like no no
so i'm just locked in i think i'm just
looking at the sidewalk or something
uh but then it was right about the
corner of
oak street and westgate there and wide
awake wiley texas i look up and it's
like you know my eyes have been down i
look up
and i just freeze because i the world
it was like it was shining it was not
like the sun was brighter than usual
honestly
i don't i don't have words to describe
it
but it was bright it was like it was
just it was shining
and suddenly i was just overcome by the
beauty of the world
uh and like all of my little mental
games
just whoosh and suddenly
uh these words just came to me and and
again this is not like
this was not you know an audible voice
of god or something um so it's very hard
to describe
but i i just these words they just came
to me almost like a command and this was
the command
bret all you have to do is
love that was the command
and standing there at the corner of
oaken west gate
i remember i got like emotional i'm sure
i looked at this point like a crazy
person
um even though now i was sane that's
what's interesting this was now i
actually found my sanity but i probably
looked crazier because there i mean i
just have like tears coming down
and my mouth's just hanging open and
i just stand there for a minute or two
and finally i i keep walking
and i just had this perfect piece all
the way home
it lingered with me um honestly for the
next few hours
and like i said the mental arguing
stopped
uh the anxiety stuff i was just at home
in the world and honestly those words
have never really left me
um all you have to do is love
and i mean to be clear i'm not always
faithful to that command
um but to this day they're they're like
a prophetic word there i i journaled
after that
and i i often return to that journal
entry
all you have to do is love it was
um it was my own little
mini burning bush uh moment
now um let me be really clear i am no
moses
uh but i think it's honestly it's not
unusual
for us to have uh at least
one or two perhaps more
of these kinds of moments in our lives
uh perhaps you've had a moment like this
and um the thing is it's easy
to forget that it ever
happened and um
but here's the thing like even even if
you're listening to me and you're
thinking
like brett i don't actually believe in
god uh i'd still put this question to
you
like have you had a moment like this
because honestly i've had a lot of
conversations with people on this topic
and it's amazing how even quite you know
kind of day-to-day secular people like
if you ask them
about their life trajectory like
why did you why do you engage that cause
or
why'd you marry that person or why'd you
go into that line of work
like what what's behind what's the story
behind that
and consistently it will be these
very kind of weird not rational
dare i say it god moments
that led them there
why why
because earth's crammed with heaven
and every common bush a fire
with god but only he who sees takes off
his shoes the rest sit round it in pluck
blackberries so the story continues
verse 7 the lord said i have indeed
seen the misery of my people in egypt i
have heard them crying out
because of their slave drivers and i am
concerned
about their suffering so i have come
down to rescue them from the hand of the
egyptians
and to bring them up out of that land
into a good
and spacious land god said a land
flowing with milk and honey
the home of the canaanites the hittites
the amorites the perizzites the hivites
the jebusites
and verse nine and now the cry of the
israelites has reached me
and i have seen the way the egyptians
are oppressing them
so now go i am sending you to pharaoh to
bring my people to israelites out
of egypt what i want you to notice here
is the connection between moses
encounter with god
what you might call his god experience
and a call a a command
that god gives him in other words this
was not a
snazzy you know goosebumps god
experience
for the sake of an experience what what
was going on
god had a purpose in his revelation
and noticed that in moses case it had
social
political even economic implications for
him
and i think what this shows is how in
the bible spirituality
and social engagement are always
intertwined
they're always two sides of the same
point uh which is weird though because
you know even many churches like we
often seem kind of intent on separating
them i think for example of my more um
kind of charismatic brothers and sisters
this is really the tradition i grew up
in
uh and we were you know we were all
about the god experiences all about
um people you know experiencing god
speaking in tongues um
seeing miracles happen receiving a word
from the lord
soaking in god's presence which to be
clear
i am all for i i think honestly i can
use more time
being intentional about just being with
god that's beautiful
but but then what happens well
what we're tempted to do is become
content to just stay there
right just just endlessly soaking in the
lord's presence
god you're so amazing god has since your
presence you are so good
but this begs the question to what end
right what what are all of these god
experiences
uh like where are they leading me what
am i being
empowered for well in the case of moses
it was pretty clear and it's captured in
that
that little little word in verse 10 you
might have caught it
so now go god said
i am sending you to pharaoh to bring my
people the israelites out
of egypt notice the lord does not say to
moses
i want you to build a little chapel here
and in this bush this will forever be a
flame this will be a holy place
and then the world gets scary moses i
want you to retreat here i want you to
just run here
i'll be here and uh i'll be your
shield from the world no
what does he say the opposite he says go
and do what well a few things i mean
he's calling him to
step out of his comfort zone and lead
he's calling him to get involved in the
messiness of the world he's calling him
to lead
on behalf of the poor and oppressed in
other words this is not a nifty god
experience for the sake of a god
experience
that this is a call to be a
spirit-empowered person right in the
midst
of the world reflecting on this passage
this exact um text in exodus richard
rohr
writes these words he says this is the
foundational text for teaching
the essential relationship between
spirituality
and social engagement prayer
and politics contemplation and
action but as i named above we're
forever tempted to split these things
up and it seems god is forever trying to
tie them back together
and this can happen institutionally
right where you have certain
organizations and churches that are
really good
maybe at prayer and perhaps teaching but
don't really get into the mess of each
other's lives
uh or even the people in their
communities lives
or as i named above this can even play
out in a personal way
right and it's sometimes it's just along
the lines of personality um for example
you you might have one person
uh who is just mr or mrs service you
know they're just loving others and
perhaps they're like a people person and
so they just love to get out there and
in the community um but you know ask
them to be alone in silence with god and
kind of face themselves for 10 minutes
and they're like
no no no no no no
uh or of course the reverse can be true
right you have the
the natural kind of contemplative who
just loves a good
i don't know silent retreat or engaging
prayer and study they love a good book
but ask them to start spending their
life energy on behalf of
of someone other than the two or three
people that they actually care about in
the world
and they're like no
no see we're forever trying to untie
these two things
but in this text we see that god used
the season of isolation
where moses was a shepherd and we see
that he used this moment of
revelation at the burning bush to do
what to commission
to send moses
so again think back to
that that that kind of significant
god moment in your life
and here's my follow-up question where
was god leading you
what was he nudging you towards
or if it actually came in the form of
words what did he
say and
kind of another key question would be
how faithful
have you been to it
have you forgotten it have you kind of
drifted as the months and years have
passed um and don't say
like oh it's just it's just a small
thing
i'm like yeah i know moses um called to
lead some nation
like i'm just it was just a little thing
god you know i don't even know
really i don't have details like don't
say that
don't say your thing doesn't matter
because i've been thinking all week how
i mean anytime we have these kind of
moments like surely it's significant
surely like if anything matters
that mattered but but i think sometimes
it's you know it's such a it
feels like such a small thing i mean
even mine you know like
all you have to do is love you know what
does that mean
well i mean it's kind of clear but it's
just not easy um but
maybe there's no grand you know i don't
know
like something more grandiose uh so this
is what we do
right we just kind of feel like it's
small um but i think the truth
is when it comes to these kind of god
experiences there are no small things
see we we think we know what what
actions we take are the big things the
important things
as opposed to the small things but
because we aren't god
we don't actually know and in being
faithful to that call and maybe it's
just to love this one person
right to to text them
to reach out to them to be in touch with
them i mean
if you kind of think of how that could
play out those texts
those just might save their life i'm
being faithful to to visit that person
in prison
or to mentor that child like
who knows how that that kind of ripple
effect plays out over the years
if you're taking notes write this down
it's not your job
to judge the size or the significance
of your call it's your job to be
faithful
to it it's not your job to judge
right we get very judgey with ourselves
that's not our role
to judge the size of the significance
it's your job
to be faithful to it
some of you may know that a few years
ago this kind of made the news
uh joanne crock she's the the wife to
the famous ray kroc who helped like
start mcdonald's and whatever
um so she made this very very
large um donation uh it was 1.6
billion dollars that's right not million
billion dollars you imagine uh
and so she made this donation and it was
to the nonprofit organization uh that
you've probably heard of it's known as
the salvation army
and so a writer his name's leonard sweet
he was
um he heard about this and he was just
dying to kind of get the inside scoop on
this
story he had some connections there at
salvation army
and he wanted to like figure out like or
hear the story like how on earth
did this happen so he finally
he gets the chance to sit down with
general linda
bond so ms bond she kind of holds the
top position at the salvation army
and she was the leader when this gift
from joanna crock occurred
so he sits down dinner with general bond
and he says
i only have one question for you like
how on
earth did you broker that deal like
i know people don't give gifts like that
large
to just the institution they give it to
a person
they trust almost almost a person or
leader that
that kind of embodies or like is kind of
a symbol of the institution
so i'm presuming it's you
uh how how how did you do this
and she looked at
sweet and she said uh no
no joanne crock didn't give the gift to
me
uh i mean yes we we bonded but no
it wasn't honestly really about me
and sweet he was a little bit
dumbfounded and he just said like well
how like why did she give it um
partly his skepticism was that um joanna
kroc was kind of a known sort of
liberal democrat in the salvation army
is you know not that it's quite a you
know conservative kind of christian
institution
so he was just like wow
what is going on 1.6 billion dollars
and so he's like okay explain and
general bonds said well here's the thing
um joanne crock came from incredibly
humble beginnings
she was brought up very poor in a not so
good part of saint paul minnesota
and she was raised during the great
depression during that whole season
um her father was was mostly unemployed
and he he had some um
drinking issues and so he would often
basically just leave the family
without food without money um and he
would just
leave for like weeks at a time and so
they would go without food and even
without heat
there in um st paul in the winter and
often um joan had explained or sorry
joanne had explained to
um general bond that she had said like i
i didn't know if we would make it um how
we'd make it even through the week
but there was one thing one moment
each week that joanne looked forward to
as a child
and it was when a salvation army
officer would drop by
every friday evening to deliver
bags of groceries
and uh this officer
like normally you have to go into the
salvation army to pick it up
and we don't know why but for whatever
reason this officer just
really cared and so he took the time
every week to
drop off their groceries
and bond went on to explain that he
didn't only
just deliver the food but he would take
time
to play with joanne and of course her
father
was like out of the picture and so this
salvation army officer
became this incredibly just
positive healthy you know male
figure and role model in joanne's life
at a time when she just didn't have that
and so leonard tweet he asks general
bond and says like
oh my gosh so it was m and she said yeah
it was him
and he said do you know his name and she
said
no i don't think anyone does and he said
do you think
like he's still alive and she said i
mean that was a
long time ago we're talking great
depression uh i mean
almost positive he's not s
and sweet said so he he died without
knowing this
and general bond said uh yeah
yeah you could you could put it that way
now imagine with me for a moment
that you are this salvation army
officer and you at some point in your
life you've sent some kind of call some
kind of draw to this
world um but you have spent
your life mostly in behind the scenes
quiet service you have lived in
obscurity
and you've tried to love and do your
best but honestly like you have
no idea that
that little girl you're visiting will go
on to be a billionaire and you just
brokered a 1.6
billion like literally the largest
charitable donation in world history
congratulations like this is
mind-blowing and this is
this is what i it gets me to thinking
about as i think about like my life and
your lives
is what a remarkable thing to consider
that you and i will likely not
be aware of the single greatest most
impactful most far-reaching moment
of our lives and that that's
unbelievable to think about like just
like that salvation army officer
like in that moment whenever that moment
comes for you like you will probably
just return home to your friends and
family and they'll ask so how's your day
and you'll be like oh it was fine and
you'll have no idea
the life you just saved
the person you just impacted
the new possibility that
entered someone's worldwide
because you cared
and because you were faithful
to god's call
you see earth's crammed with heaven
in every common bush is a
fire with god but only he
who sees only he who takes off
his shoes the rest set around it
and pluck blackberries
so as i think of us let's be um
let's be the community that cease
that takes off our shoes that is
faithful to the call
and man i just wonder what on earth
could god
do if we were faithful
to that vision amen
all right let me let me go ahead and
pray for you lord jesus
um i pray that we would learn
to be the people who see
may we learn to to notice
to tune in to see you shining in and
through
all things and all people god may we
see as the mystic see
and may we not waste our lives in
distraction and blackberries
but may we have those spiritual eyes god
lead us forward the name of jesus i pray
amen
[Music]
i could just sit
i could just sit and wait for
all your goodness i could just stay
i could just stay right where i am
[Music]
i could hold on
me lord
you have called me
[Music]
will you higher me
i will be yours
[Music]
i will be yours for all my life
i will be yours
i will be yours for all my
[Music]
like the path before me you
have caught me higher
[Music]
higher
deeper and i'll go where you will lead
[Music]
me
you'll lead me
thank you so much for joining us this
evening if you are in need of prayer or
support
please send the table a facebook message
or you can email us
on our website for those of you that
support the table financially
thank you your gifts empower us to carry
on this work
if you would like to support the table
please visit our website
at thetabletx.org
don't forget about the be the bridge and
enneagram meetups
there will be a link in the comments if
you would like to sign up or get more
information
all right let me send you off into your
week with a blessing written by
dr john buchanan
by god's grace we are the body of christ
and because of that let us go into the
world in peace
and courage hold on to the good
all of god's children loving and serving
the lord
rejoicing in the power of the spirit and
the grace of the lord jesus christ
the love of god and the communion of the
holy spirit
be with you all amen hope to see you
back next week
you